>> Hi, everyone. I'm Ario from the Authors
at Google program.
And it's -- very happy to introduce Scott
Berkun today, who's our speaker.
He's going to be talking about public speaking.
And he's famous for just having great pieces
that he writes on his blog.
And he's written three excellent books for
O'Reilly.
So please give him a warm welcome.
And I'll hand it off to Scott.
>> [Clapping]
Scott Berkun: How are you doing?
You hear me okay? Volume good?
Loud enough in the back?
Still awake? Good. Excellent. Okay.
So, my first confession I want to share with
you is that I am not an extrovert.
I am not someone who -- at the age of five
-- told my mom, "I want to be a public speaker
when I grow up."
That is not who I am.
And the fact that I've written a book about
public speaking is kind of an odd story.
And the story goes something like this: I
actually believe in ideas.
I'm a creative person.
I believe in ideas and learning about ideas
and sharing them and trying to think better
and share stuff that I find that's important
or can make the world better.
That is why I quit my job to write books.
But a funny thing happens when you do anything
interesting.
A funny thing happens when you write books
is that people want you to talk about the
stuff that you've written.
And in all the stuff that I've done about
the history of innovation, a lot of my work
is on creative thinking and the history of
how ideas become things and affect the world.
Is that's one of the threads that runs through
all those stories too.
Is that if you invent a cure for a disease
-- if you create something that earns a patent
-- eventually someone's going to want you
to come and talk about those ideas.
And the quality how you talk about your ideas
is going to affect how they perceive the quality
of the actual ideas themselves.
So, I've sort of stumbled backwards into becoming
a public speaker.
And then, I recognize that -- if you care
about ideas and you care about progress, that
eventually your communication skills are really
the gaining factors to what you can make happen
in the world.
So I quit my job. I used to work at Microsoft.
I worked on Internet Explorer in the early
days.
But I quit my job at Microsoft in 2003 to
write books.
And as a side effect of writing books that
have had the good fortune to be successful,
I've done lots and lots of public speaking.
I've been on national television. I've been
on NPR.
I've been flown all over the world to give
lectures on stuff basically that I had written
about, which -- if you think about it -- is
a really kind of lousy reason to hire someone
to speak.
Because just because you can write well has
almost no bearing on the fact that you can
speak well.
So over the course of the last ten years or
so, I've probably given hundreds of lectures.
I've taught college courses. I've taught workshops.
I've been on all different kinds of media.
And because I care about ideas, I've become
someone who cares a lot about communication.
And I felt like, of all the books I had seen
or come across about public speaking, they
all tend to be very dry and kind of generic.
And I know, from my own mistakes, that I have
all these fantastic stories of doing really
stupid, embarrassing things in front of other
people.
And I've learned from those mistakes how to
do this stuff well.
And that's what the book is about.
It's a capturing of all the stuff that I have
talked about -- all the stuff that has gone
wrong for me and what the lessons are that
can be learned from anyone else.
You know, for any of you who are following
online -- any Twitterers here -- any Twitter
users, anybody? Couple of you.
If you want to tweet as we're going, you want
to blog as we're going, you want to take pictures
of me or send smoke signals, you're free to
use whatever media you want at all, because
I'm here promoting the book.
So feel free to distract yourself from what
I'm saying if you're going to talk about what
I'm doing to people who aren't here.
You know, the first thing you should know
about public speaking is that, we are all
public speakers.
That everyone speaks all the time.
And on average -- the average American says
about 12,000 words a day.
12,000 words a day.
Now, of course, since there's no actual, average
person, there's probably no one person who
just says 12,000 words.
Some people say as few as five.
Some people say as many as 20.
We all have a friend who probably says more
than 20,000 words a day that we'd rather that
they didn't.
But we're all speakers.
And in our ordinary lives, the fact that you
have a job, the fact that you have friends,
the fact that you have a girlfriend or boyfriend
-- the only way that you communicate to share
a life with them is through speaking and telling
stories and explaining what it is you're trying
to do with your life.
So we are all inherently good speakers.
Anyone who's listening to this conversation,
listening to me talk right now, we're all
good speakers.
The problem, though, is as soon as you get
into a environment where you are like I am
right now -- at the front of the room with
a microphone with a bunch of people who you
don't know staring at you -- all the dynamics
start to change.
It gets kind of weird now.
You feel judged. You feel you're going to
be challenged.
You feel vulnerable.
And because of those feelings, your natural
abilities to tell stories and to communicate
clearly -- diminishes.
The other problem that we have when it comes
to public speaking is that most of the public
speaking that we experience in our lives -- in
high school and in college -- is really bad.
Like, most public speaking is bad. It's boring;
it's dull.
There's a reason why the word 'lecture' is
not a compliment.
It's kind of an insult. It's a pejorative.
People say, "Stop lecturing me."
So we know that there's all these bad habits
that most people have when they speak.
But whenever it's our turn -- whenever most
people get the opportunity to be up in front
of a room, the thing they do is repeat all
the same mistakes they saw other people do,
because they think that's just how it's done.
So what I'm going to do for the next 20 minutes
or so, I'm going to give a very -- I'm going
to pick the stuff that most bad speakers do,
and explain to you how not to do it, which
is the easiest, most 'low-hanging fruit' way
in the world to get better at being a speaker.
And the first one -- actually, before I jump
into the first one -- these are the six I'm
going to talk about.
It'll take me about 25 minutes to get through
all this stuff.
And then, we'll have about 20 minutes or so
for Q and A.
So as I'm going along, if I'm not talking
about the thing you hoped I would talk about
when you came into this room, keep that in
the back of your mind, and we'll have plenty
of time at the end to talk about those things
that I didn't get to.
So these are the six things that most bad
speakers do.
Now, the first one is the obvious one, which
has to do with fear of public speaking.
So how many of you get nervous before you
give a pitch or talk at a meeting or give
a lecture?
How many of you have a fear of public speaking,
just raise your hand.
Okay. So that's about seventy percent of you.
So the rest of you are liars. You are liars.
And the reason you are liars is not necessarily
because you're fully aware that you're lying,
but there's a fact -- it's biological -- that
explains the fear response people have when
they're speaking.
And it has to do with the oldest part of your
brain called the 'amygdala', which is in the
core of your brain.
It's about the size of a peanut.
And it's kind of scary when you think about
it -- this tiny part of your brain -- that's
what controls a lot of really important stuff:
Controls your heart rate, controls your adrenaline,
fight or flight response stuff.
And we have very little control over it -- by
design. By design.
Because the amygdala thinks it's smarter than
you are.
Now, evolutionarily speaking, millions of
years ago, hundreds of thousands of years
ago -- that's where the program for the amygdala
was generated -- if you were a creature standing
alone on the field in front of a large crowd
of other creatures who were staring at you
that you didn't know, that would be bad.
That would mean you're going to die or you're
going to get eaten.
That's what it would mean -- one of those
two things.
So the creatures who found this cool, and
had a positive response to this, stuck around
and died.
Those ancestors no longer are around anymore.
The ones who were afraid of it -- who were
freaked out by that kind of environment -- are
the ones who run away.
And those are our great grandparents and great
grandparents, grandparents whatever.
We are descended from that line of genetics.
So that means that, whenever you get up in
front of a crowd -- whenever you're going
to pitch an idea to someone, even if it's
in a small group -- you're going to feel that
fight or flight response kick in.
Because biologically, your body's telling
you, based on millions of years of programming,
"This is bad. This is dangerous."
So you can't control that.
You can not entirely control that.
And in all the research I did for the book,
I could not find a single example -- not one
example -- of a famous performer, a rock star,
an athlete, anyone who performs regularly
in front of crowds, that did not admit they
got nervous before they performed.
It's a universal fact, because it's biological.
What this means, though, if you're going to
speak -- it means that sometimes you'll be
nervous for reasons that have nothing to do
with how smart you are, nothing to do with
how well you prepared.
It's a physiological response that you can
not control.
So the first thing you have to do then is,
acknowledge, "Okay, I am going to be nervous.
I can't shut that off.
I have to take responsibility for all the
things that I can take care of.
I have to take responsibility for those."
You know, the first one, which is really obvious
-- if you think about it -- is, if your body
is going to have a physiological response,
you want to make sure you get exercise that
day.
The average American gets way below what their
genetic disposition is for how much exercise
they need to get.
So if you actually exercise your body that
morning and exhaust your body's natural fear
response energy -- that nervous energy -- you'll
be way calmer, because your body's calmed
down.
So, it's physiological -- physiological problem
-- solve it through physiological means.
The other thing you have to think about are
all the things that are within your control,
which means like getting to the place early,
which helps your body calm down that you're
in the environment that you're going to be
speaking in.
Or whatever material you use, you have to
practice it.
All this stuff that people tend to discount
as being irrelevant to the fear.
Those are things you can control, you have
to make sure that you take care of those things.
You know, the second thing that many speakers
do that's a problem is that they allow themselves
to be perceived as never having done what
they're doing before that they make it look
like it's their first time.
And no one in the world wants to be a guinea
pig.
No one wants to feel like they are the experiment.
This is the first time this guy's ever done
this demo.
That's why he hasn't figured out how it works.
And he's going to spend ten minutes fiddling
with his laptop.
No one wants to feel that way.
And, although it's more of a superficial complaint
about speakers in general, if you take the
time to make sure that you practice all the
things that you do so it seems natural to
you, it makes it much easier for people to
follow along with whatever it is you're saying.
So it's an obligation you have if you're speaking.
Now, I have about -- there's probably about
a hundred people in this room right now.
And there's only one of me.
If I'm going to spend an hour talking, that
means there's a hundred hours that have been
spent by you listening.
If I'm looking to practice for a couple of
hours, then I am creating "public speaking
hour debt."
Because there's 97 or 99 hours are being spent
by you and only one that's spent by me.
If I don't practice, I'm effectively telling
you, "My one hour is more important than your
99," which is really an offensive kind of
way to think about public speaking.
So anything you do -- anything you're going
to talk about, anything you're going to show
-- you have to practice it.
So at least it feels natural to you, and it
makes it easier for people who are going to
follow along with whatever it is that you're
going to say.
My third point has to do with rhythm.
Are any of you guys musicians?
Even amateur musicians? Anyone play guitar?
What do you play in the back?
A I play guitar.
Scott Berkun: Any drummers? Percussion? No
drummers.
We'll have to rely on you then, my friend.
Do you play rhythm guitar?
A Sometimes.
Scott Berkun: Okay, there we go.
So, it turns out -- and you'll know this -- it
turns out that most -- we are all rhythmic
creatures.
We all have a heart rate that's relatively
constant that gives us a steady pace for how
we absorb all the information that's out there
when we're trying to pay attention.
There's a beat that exists just within us.
And one of the main problems in most lectures
-- in most public speaking -- is that the
pace is always really slow.
Lectures are boring, because the pace is slow.
And that's a problem.
But what's worse than a slow lecture is a
slow lecture that's erratic.
So I have a picture up here of a turtle for
a reason.
So, turtles are slow. No argument there.
Anyone want to argue about that?
Turtle's slow? Turtles are slow.
I've never seen a fast turtle.
The only thing worse -- and I know in my life,
sometimes I get frustrated from standing behind
someone in line who's slow, because I'm waiting
for them to do their thing.
I got to get past them.
The only thing that's worse than being behind
a turtle is being behind a turtle that's on
drugs.
So a turtle on drugs is still slow.
You're not going to fix that through biochemistry.
But turtle on drugs is now going to be erratic.
So it's slow and erratic, which is much worse.
Because slow and predictable means you at
least know, "Okay, it's going to take a certain
amount of time for this guy to get through
his stuff and then he's going to move on to
the next thing."
Slow and unpredictable means you're going
to have this kind of experience where you're
going to be in the audience -- someone's in
the audience -- you're going like, "He's been
going for 20 minutes like, has he started
yet?
What is he talking about?" That's a turtle
on drugs.
It's someone who's not figured out that there's
pace and rhythm that's important anytime someone's
speaking.
And if the person speaking isn't controlling
the pace and the rhythm in some way, it's
very difficult for people to follow along.
In doing research for the book, one of the
angles I took was to dig up all the research
that's been done about lecturing and all the
cognitive psychology and the cognitive science
about what goes on in our brains when we're
listening to lectures.
And to condense that down in a fairly unscientific
and made-for-television kind of way, the best
basic rule of thumb about attention is, most
people on average can pay attention for about
five to ten minutes.
That's a sweet-spot number for if you're going
to make a rough assumptions about crowds of
people, that's your number.
Five to ten minutes.
So that means if ever you're giving a lecture,
it's going to be a half hour, or you're giving
a talk, or anything that goes longer than
that, you have to be thinking about how to
construct your material in units of five to
seven minutes, creating a rhythm that's going
to be easier for people to follow along with.
Very basic.
One mistake most people make, though, is when
you're doing a presentation or giving a pitch
or -- you usually use a keynote or Powerpoint.
Who here has used keynote or Powerpoint in
the last week?
Okay. Most of you, right?
The flaw is, people usually think then in
terms of slides.
How many slides am I going to have?
But a slide is not a measure of time.
So if you're thinking about your presentation,
"Oh, yeah.
I got 30 slides. That seems about right."
You could end up spending 20 minutes talking
about one slide, or maybe go quickly through
30 slides and only do that within five minutes.
So you have to be thinking about the pace
chronologically rather than in terms of the
content material.
You're trying to make it easy for people to
follow along through what you're going to
say.
The other bit of research that I dug up, which
is pretty fun -- although lecturing is the
dominant form of communication that teachers
use and professors have used for probably
hundreds of years, there's been very little
research done as to what's actually going
on physiologically for people who are in the
audience.
So there's this guy Bly, who's a professor
and a researcher who wrote this excellent
book about all the science behind teaching.
And in the book, he explains a study that
he did that no one had ever done before.
He's a professor, and he's like, "Hey, I want
to find out what's actually going on for people
who are listening to lectures."
So he took his class -- college students -- strapped
them all up to heart rate monitors, and then
lectured to them.
And this is what happened, you know.
Not a surprise, because most of you probably
went to college and you fell asleep in at
least one class.
I'm sure how many fell asleep in at least
one class.
Yeah, this is part of the process, right,
we know?
But there's actually data.
He's like, "Look, your bodies are clearly
not built to be lectured to."
We're built to hunt and gather and do all
kinds of active things.
And sitting and listening is entirely passive.
So this means, if you're a speaker -- and
again, you're speaking for a length of time
-- you have to do something to help people's
natural physiology work with you rather than
against you.
So instead of being a turtle on crack or turtle
on drugs where you have an inconsistent rhythm,
"It doesn't really make any sense," you need
to be constructing your stuff with a pace
that, at least, is clear to you.
Preferably, it's clear to whoever you're talking
to.
You're telling them, "I've got five things
to say.
I'm going to spend 30 minutes going through
those five."
Then, at least, people know there's a pace
they can follow.
One trick -- one question I get asked a lot
is, What to do when people start losing interest?
What do you do when people start tuning out?
And my answer to that question is always the
same.
It's like, "People tune out all the time."
Especially today, in 2009, with all the things
we can carry with us that are fun distractions.
People tune out all the time.
Or they start thinking about, "Wait, did I
walk the dog this morning?
I can't remember." Or "What am I going to
have for dinner tonight?"
All these things that run through people's
minds. And that's fine.
But if you don't provide a rhythm, you don't
provide a pace, then when they tune out, they're
probably gone for the entire lecture, or the
entire talk.
If you provide some kind of rhythm, then you
give a trigger that they'll hear.
They'll go, "Oh, wait. Oh, right. I'm in a
lecture now.
What is he talking about? Oh, he moved on
to the next point. Okay."
And there's some way for them to come back
in.
You never want to be in a position where you
go on for 30 minutes and people who've tuned
out, they have no way they could possibly
come back in and join the rest of the crowd.
And speaking of crowds -- I mentioned earlier
on, I sort of gave you a compliment for being
a human being and that "We're all good at
speaking."
It's something we all do.
But I have to admit that there are people
who can make anything boring.
That you could have a super-exciting thing
happen.
You could, I don't know -- you could be in
a car accident or meet a famous person on
the street who gives you a thousand dollars
just because he liked you that day.
Some amazing story.
And then you go somewhere else and you're
about to tell that story to other people and
your friend starts telling the story, and
he totally blows it.
He tells it in the most long-winded way.
Starts talking about what he had for breakfast
that morning and just rambling on and on.
And you're like, "Oh, my God."
Because you were there and you know what happened.
So it's possible -- despite all of our natural
instincts for communication -- it is possible
to make anything boring.
Typically, by including too much.
Typically, when you include too much, it makes
things boring.
If your goal is to be comprehensive, it makes
Good stories are never comprehensive.
Never, ever comprehensive.
They have a narrative. They have a hook.
They have some line of thinking that's interesting
or piques your curiosity, and they run with
that hook.
So, the bad news is, there are some people
-- and maybe some of you -- I haven't had
anything exciting happen yet with you in the
room that I can tell you how you would tell
a story about it.
But, while it's possible that you can make
anything boring, the counterpoint -- which
is good -- is that it's also possible to make
anything interesting.
You can make anything interesting.
And that's what good storytellers do.
That's what good speakers do.
That's what good salesmen do.
They find a way to make the thing they're
talking about interesting to you.
And I have two tricks for this -- two tricks
that make it easier to do.
The metaphor that works best is to think of
a pitch -- where you're trying to convince
someone of something or a meeting or presentation
-- to think of it as a path.
You, as the pitcher -- as the presenter -- you're
trying to create a path that people can follow
along on.
They want to make it so they're interested
all the way through.
And the metaphor works best when you think
about, People are going to take the next step
if they're interested.
The word 'interesting' is probably the best
word when you're thinking about trying to
keep people's attention.
And there are two easy ways to use that word
to your advantage.
Now, the first one is the easiest, but it's
low-hanging fruit.
It doesn't have a huge payoff.
And that is, if ever you're trying to convince
someone of something -- you have something
you want to talk about, some knowledge you
want to share -- you have to make sure you
found an angle to talk about it that, at least,
you're interested in personally.
That you found a way to find meaning in whatever
it is, so it matters to you.
All the research about communication and speaking
and teaching -- there is this factor.
It's entirely -- I don't want to say 'superficial',
but we put a lot of weight on people's enthusiasm.
It makes a huge difference.
People's retention -- their ability to pay
attention, their ability to learn and recall
facts -- goes up when the person who gave
those things to them was enthusiastic.
So, how do you become enthusiastic?
Well, you have to make sure whatever you're
talking about, you found a way to think about
it -- however boring it might be -- you found
a way to think about it that's at least interesting
to you.
And the trick for this -- one trick -- is
to think about, instead of the technology
that you're talking about, or the information
you're talking about, which is kind of abstract
and maybe kind of boring, but to think about
the effect you want that information to have
on the world.
That it can have an effect that you care about.
And that's the passion that you need to make
sure carries on through in whatever it is
that you're talking about.
Whether that's a line of code, whether that's
some idea for a product or feature -- think
about the effect.
It's much easier to get excited about effects
and people and the effects your idea or that
thing can have on people.
So that's the easier one.
The harder one, which is the higher payoff,
but requires more work is, to think about
the people who are in the audience and why
they're there.
Many people when they present -- they give
a lecture or even when they teach a college
course -- they get wrapped up in themselves.
Well, what do I want to talk about?
How should I make this slide? Ooh, this is
a fun story to tell.
And it becomes very selfish and egocentric,
which -- if you think about the world from
a design or user experience perspective -- is
a fatal mistake.
Instead, what you want to do is say, "Hey,
why are these people coming?
They have a thousand other things they could
do.
Why are they going to sit here and listen?
What are the questions they're likely to have?
What did I put in the description that set
them up?
What expectations are they going to have?
How do I take all the knowledge or wisdom
or stories that I have and put that in a format
that's interesting to the people who are coming?"
Does not take a whole lot of work to do this
-- especially, if you're speaking somewhere
where there's a host who's invited you in
or it's a conference or it's an event of some
kind.
They have data about who shows up and why.
How old they are. What degrees they have.
What background they have.
How many years they've been in the industry.
Or, there's a thousand questions that you
can ask that all of a sudden feed your thinking
as to what the artifact of a presentation,
what problem it's intended to solve for the
people who show up.
Most of the time when you are bored, it means
the person who's speaking -- and if you're
bored right now, this applies to me as well.
It means the person who's speaking did not
think carefully enough -- or possibly not
even at all about why you're here.
Don't ever let that happen to you.
If you're thinking clear about why people
are there -- even if you don't like public
speaking, even if you don't think of yourself
as charismatic, even if you talk into your
shoes -- if you're talking about stuff people
really care about, they will pay attention.
You know, a simple trick is to think about
-- people talk all the time about how to
keep people's attention as if there's some
gimmick to it.
But, if I went -- if this lecture -- if I
were to switch gears and say, "What this lecture's
really about is I'm going to give away $500
million at the end of this lecture and I'm
going to talk for the next 20 minutes about
how I'm going to choose who gets the money."
All of a sudden, it's interesting.
No matter what superficial things as a speaker
I'm not doing well.
On the other end of the spectrum, you could
have Tony Robins or Barack Obama or some great
charismatic speaker, and if you asked him
to speak for 20 minutes about who's going
to help with his taxes or something, your
interest level would drop.
So a lot of the whole game is matching the
stuff that you think you're supposed to share
or you have that's valuable to the people
who are there and make sure that Venn diagram
is a rich Venn diagram -- that you're covering
both stuff that make it interesting to you,
but also make it interesting to them.
So instead of being the kind of guy who tells
these long-winded stories and is comprehensive,
you've thought about it carefully.
You've at least found a way to make it interesting
yourself.
Maximally, you've found a way to think about
why people are there, and you're solving those
problems for them.
We're on the home stretch now.
I have two more of these.
So if you're thinking, "Man, he still hasn't
talked about my thing."
Keep it in mind.
Because we'll have Q and A in about ten minutes.
Maybe eight minutes. Seven minutes.
Five minutes. Soon. [laughter]
So, this point -- it has to do with being
smart.
And you guys are all smart.
A lot of smart people out there.
Smart people often make a smart person's mistake
when it comes to presenting a pitch.
Because there's this habit that many smart
people have of, When you're in an argument
and you start to lose, you increase the syllable
count per word.
Like the vocabulary complexity goes up.
And you're betting, at some point, you'll
use a word that the other person doesn't understand.
And since you're in an argument, they're not
going to say, "I don't know what that means."
They're just going to back out of the argument,
and you're going to win by like, technical
knock out. [laughter]
That you've now done this, "Okay, you win."
You're like, "Yes."
Does not actually mean the argument was sound.
It means you used kind of a technicality -- a
word they didn't know -- to win.
This habit is a defensive way to communicate.
You are actually -- literally, you're trying
to push people away.
And any time I see someone use a lot of jargon
-- any time I see someone making choices
where they are picking complex words rather
than simple, even though a simple one is probably
just as good, they are saying, "Back off.
I am pushing you away.
I really don't want you to understand.
I don't really want you to follow along on
my path.
I'm pushing you away."
That's a response many smart people have when
they're up here, because you feel vulnerable
up here.
We feel like we're going to be attacked.
So we want to push people away.
The goal instead, though, of allowing rhetoric
to be the flaw is to think again about what
the whole purpose of all this is.
If you're actually speaking about something
you care about, then you want people to follow
along.
If you have an idea you're trying to convince
someone to adopt or give you money for or
support in some way, you want them to be on
your side.
So this approach of being complex first is
never going to work.
Instead, you have to be thinking the opposite
way.
What's the simplest way I can explain what
it is my purpose is?
I'm trying to make the world better. Well,
how?
Whatever the high-level goal is, you have
to make sure that becomes clear first -- and
enthusiastically.
And then, you follow up with the things that
are more complex and more advanced, assuming
people can follow along with you.
And I studied philosophy in college.
And there's this thing about rhetoric that
is very important when it comes to speaking.
And it has to do with the difference between
points and arguments.
Points and arguments.
A 'point' is the message -- the five things
you want people to leave with or the actions
you want them to take.
That's the point of what you're doing.
Whether that's a pitch, whether that's an
idea pitch, whether that's a status meeting,
there's a set of things you want to make clear.
And those have to be crystal clear.
There should never be someone who leaves listening
to you and is not clear on what your points
were, which is separate from the arguments
for those points.
The arguments that support the points, "Okay,
maybe people won't agree with those, or be
confused by them.
They didn't fully understand my rationale.
But they should never misunderstand the purpose
that I was trying to get across."
So points and arguments.
And many times, when you're in a bad lecture
or bad presentation, they've never figured
out -- the speaker has never thought through
enough to clarify what the points are and
what the arguments were.
Instead, it's just this, you know, this blob
of facts and stories and data that doesn't
make any sense.
Coherence comes largely from, Before you sit
down and make a slide, writing down what the
things are you want people to leave with:
The five things they should learn.
The five new ideas they should have.
The five questions they should now be prepared
to answer.
If you don't know what those five things are,
then there's almost no chance that anyone's
going to leave with anything at all.
So points and arguments.
Make sure your points are clear.
And I highly recommend not starting in Powerpoint
or keynote when you start a talk, because
that will largely get you on the track of
putting this stuff in.
It's fun to do.
Makes you feel like you're making progress
quickly, but you really have not thought at
all about your audience.
You have not thought at all about the things
you want them to leave with.
That requires your brain.
No software tool can really do that for you.
Speaking of software and slides.
I'm not a huge believer in slides being the
problem.
If -- we're almost done here -- if you do
the four, five things I've talked about already,
then by the time you get to making slides,
most of your problems that people create with
slides will go away.
But I have to talk about at least for a minute.
So this is a very typical kind of slide.
This is, you know, a generic template you
can find in almost any presentation tool,
with a bulleted list and a title at the top.
And there are all these rules you might have
heard about, like, how to do these well.
Seven by seven.
Has anyone heard of the seven by seven rule?
There's a rule for this, that you're supposed
to -- if ever you have bullets, you should
have -- this is my bad advice voice -- "If
ever you have a bulleted slide, you should
have seven bullets and never more than seven
words per bullet."
Sounds like, "Okay."
Now, who made this up?
Like, what research did they do on this?
I have no idea, because there probably isn't
any.
When I see a slide like this, I'm always -- especially
when someone asks me to look at their slide
deck -- like before they're going to give
a talk -- I know, right off the bat, this
is someone who has made a bunch of mistakes
we've talked about already.
First, it probably means they didn't practice.
They don't know what they're going to say.
So they've listed a whole bunch of stuff in
the hopes that one of those things will make
sense when they're up here speaking.
Second, if they haven't practiced, it increases
the odds when there's this much density on
the screen, they're going to do this.
And they're going to turn and talk to their
slides.
Because they're almost a conversation.
There's so much language here, they're going
to end up having a conversation with the slides.
And turning your back on your audience, there's
a whole bunch of very bad things.
I mean, in some countries when you do this,
you'll get killed. [laughter]
Not appropriate to do.
And it also -- any energy or enthusiasm, theatrically,
should be directed at the audience.
As soon as you turn -- even if you're just
going back and forth -- it diffuses your energy,
which is a bad thing to do.
The other problem with this kind of stuff:
Bullet lists tend to make speakers feel like
they are obligated to speak to everything
on there.
So it becomes comprehensive again.
Now, there's all this stuff that I feel like
"I got to say this" and "I got to say that,"
which is boring and repetitive.
And you're unlikely to be enthusiastic about
it.
So when you have this much visual density
-- in terms of language, there's a lot of
stuff here -- it usually means they didn't
practice.
They did not think what their points were,
right off the bat.
The other end of visual density has to do
with actual, visual, graphic design stuff.
So this is another slide.
This is an actual slide from the Department
of Defense.
And it's a report on the Iraqi war from a
couple years ago.
And when I see this slide -- without knowing
the speaker, without knowing anything about
it -- I also can make another set of assumptions,
which again, are similar to the first one.
Does not know what he's going to say when
this is up.
There's so much data here visually and dimensionally.
I mean, he's got, you know, orange squares
and red squares and gradient squares.
And there's like this huge tree of the complexity
of stuff here.
You could talk for hours about the data represented
here, which is not what you want to do when
you're talking.
That's bad.
That means not clear.
And if I had to make a whole bunch of assumptions
even further, the goal of this meeting to
show stuff like this is probably the nature
of, "How's it going? Is it going well?"
Okay, what are the five things that are going
well?
What are the five things that are not?
What are the dimensions of those things?
And that's a simple question.
It's an important question, but it's a simple
question.
This -- don't know what the question is.
Therefore, you don't know what the answer
is.
Therefore, I can guess, the guy spent a whole
ton of time playing around with Powerpoint,
getting really excited at how much detail
he put in there, without ever thinking about
his audience or what he was going to say or
what he wanted them to leave with.
So, the goal for all the slide stuff, really,
instead of having confused slides or distracting
slides -- Slides are a prop.
They're in support of whatever it is that
you're saying.
If you need a bulleted list that actually
supports you, Great.
I've had bulleted lists in the slide deck
already.
I'm not saying, "Never use bulleted lists."
But you have to make sure they are in service
of a higher purpose -- the audience's purpose,
your purpose, and the point you're trying
to make.
And never allow them to be the focal point.
When you start out in Powerpoint -- you spend
hours in there -- you're going to tend to
want to talk about your work, because it's
your thing you're proud of.
You want to show it off.
No one really is going to care.
They came for reasons they care about that
have nothing to do with your ability to make
slides or not.
So those are the six reasons for badness -- for
evil.
To be less sarcastic or cynical, flip these
over, and these are the positive things that
I hope that you'll think about next time you
give a talk.
First, just to summarize, right off the bat.
The amygdala -- you are going to be afraid;
everyone is.
Can't turn that off.
You have to control the things you can.
At a minimum, help your body out -- get some
exercise that morning.
By far, that will make a radical difference.
You're helping your body deal with the physiological
fears involved in speaking.
Second, practice.
This is a performance.
Whether you're pitching or giving a talk in
a small group, you have some idea you're trying
to convey, there are performance aspects to
having arguments.
Even in the small.
If you don't practice it, then you're making
them the guinea pig.
And if you care about your ideas, it's a stupid
thing to do.
You want to do a dry run. You want to run
it by people.
Get their feedback on your pitch, how to make
it sharper or tighter.
Obvious easy thing to do; no technology required.
Fourth, about being interesting.
Emotion counts. Enthusiasm counts.
It's up to you to find a way to make it interesting
yourself when you open your mouth.
You could have the best idea in the world,
if you seem bored by it, we know from the
psychology -- from the cognitive psychology
data that we have -- likelihood of people
believing you and following your idea goes
down.
And then, lastly, anything you use or show
-- slides, demos, whatever it is that you
feel obligated to show -- make sure it really
supports the points.
And make sure it supports the reasons why
people came.
The slide should be a prop in support of whatever
it is that you're doing.
So those are my photo credits.
And I'm on a book tour.
I'm on the tail end of my book tour.
I'm almost done. I've been all over the place.
I've been in Boston. I've been in New York.
I've been here all week.
And tonight is my last lecture of the year,
which I am so thrilled and excited about.
And if you think I did an okay job today,
and you know someone else who may want to
come along and be entertained or learn about
the amygdala and other cool brain science
stuff, tell them to come along tonight, and
we'll probably have a really good time.
Because it's going to be -- I get kind of
goofy when it's my last lecture.
So with that, I will open the floor for Q
and A.
And think about -- you guys came here for
a reason.
And if I didn't give you what you wanted,
we have time now to try and get at it.
So who wants to start with a question?
Oh, okay. Who's got a question?
Yeah, sorry, you're going to engage your body
to make a move.
Q Hi. I'm Charles.
I was kind of interested in something that
you mentioned, kind of early on, in the presentation.
You said that you made a lot of mistakes kind
of over your years doing presentations.
So, what are maybe one of the top or the top
two things that you've done that would be
just like, were stupid mistakes?
Scott Berkun: Okay. So, the question was top
mistakes.
Well, the biggest one by far is 'not practicing'.
It's easy to see doing this as just something
that's done.
And until I started practicing before -- well,
the real story that led me down this path
is why I'm in front of you today.
I was a manager at Microsoft. I worked on
Internet Explorer.
And I was asked to give a presentation in
front of about 300 people -- biggest lecture
I'd ever done. And I did it.
And this is probably ten years ago, so I was
a lot younger then.
And I watched the video of it.
It was awful. It was just bad.
I came across as angry and unpleasant.
I gave off all the energy in the world of
not wanting to be there, but like pissed at
the audience that I had to be. [laughter]
And I was devastated, but it's not because
I'm a bad speaker, but again, I believe in
the work my team was doing.
I believe in the stuff we were making.
And I'm up here representing it.
And the fact that I behaved that way tainted
whatever it was that I had to show.
And I felt that was a kind of tragedy.
So that's when I started saying, you know,
"If I want to work on important stuff.
If I want to have ideas and convince other
people of the stuff, then I have to take responsibility
for how I communicate, because that's how
these ideas will make their way or not in
the world."
And so, most of my stories -- and a lot of
the stories in the book -- are what happens
when you do this a lot.
I mean, I've had everything go wrong.
I mean, sometimes the mistakes are not your
fault.
I've had fire alarms go off in the middle
of talks.
I've had laptops crash. I've had hecklers.
And, you know, people ask a question that
goes on for five minutes.
I've had all that stuff happen.
And then, I go back, and I'm like, "I got
to get better at this."
So I have gotten a lot better, and the book
is largely what I learned from doing this
thing.
So, I bet any mistake you can imagine, I probably
done it at some point or another.
But most of the mistakes people worry about
is stupid.
Like typos. Who cares?
Like really, this is your big criticism of
my hour -- that I spelled a word wrong?
Like, c'mon. That's the criticism?
Okay. I'll take that.
Most of the things people worry about are
trivial things, I think.
Yeah. Book for you for asking the first question.
Q Just got a question about practice.
You were just talking about how you saw yourself
in a video and that helped sort of trigger
the idea that you needed to get better.
There's a book by a guy called Daniel Coyle.
I think it was called "The Talent Code," just
talking about intentional types of practice.
Scott Berkun: Yeah.
Q Do you have tips on what are ways to practice
that really kind of extract as much value
out of that process?
Scott Berkun: Sure, so I can tell you what
I do.
And I recommend it, but you really need to
do it yourself to find what works best.
The thing that I do is, all the advice I just
offered, I follow -- I think -- most of it.
And I know that, since I want this to feel
natural, I don't spend hours making a slide
deck and then start to practice.
That's a fatal -- then I got this thing I
spent hours on, that I don't want to cut.
So I work the other way.
I think on paper -- just my list of points.
What do I think people are going to want to
know?
Or questions we want to answer.
And I fleshed it out a little bit, like a
rough outline.
And then, I start making slides.
And then, once I have like, you know, five
slides -- I have a chunk that is like rough
-- I'll start practicing.
This is ridiculous. It's embarrassing.
I'll stand up in my office alone, or I'm in
a hotel room alone, and I'll start doing it.
And I'll just go.
And usually I'll go for a minute, then, I'm
like, "I have no idea what comes next."
But then, I'll sit down and go, "Well, if
I can't get past a minute, then that part
of my outline needs more fleshing -- I need
to think more about that."
And then, I keep going, and I iterate.
And as I'm going, I'm refining my slides.
When I get stuck.
And then, eventually, I got five or ten minutes
of material that works.
And once I have that unit, then making the
rest of it's much easier, because I've put
this together.
And that prevents the problem of overdoing
the slides.
And it enforces me thinking clearly about
each part, because I'm doing it a lot.
Then, once I get up here, I've actually said
this stuff before.
And it might not be great, but it's way better
than it was the first time I said it.
So the more you actually do it -- stand up
and do it -- the better.
A lot of people, they make their slides, and
they sit there and like, flip through.
And they're thinking in their head what they're
going to say -- doesn't count.
Not practice.
That's thinking about practice.
Not the same thing.
You have to actually do it.
It's physical.
Q Sounds like agile development.
Scott Berkun: Yeah. No big schedules.
Little pieces. Book for you.
You want to come up and get it.
Q Hi Scott.
Scott Berkun: I know you.
Q I have a couple of questions.
So, the first one is, a lot of times when
we're trying to get ideas across -- and sort
of pitches across -- it's not kind of the
big lecture halls or it's like the small conference
rooms.
It might be just a few people there.
It might be a lot of people on VC.
It might be a few people.
The kind of typical thing you do is you stay
sitting.
What about the energy in those kinds of rooms?
Different from the big room.
Scott Berkun: It's different, but the principles
are the same.
And our bodies are the same.
So, even though you're sitting down or whatever,
if you find a way to describe whatever you're
talking about that you're enthusiastic about
it, people's attention will tend to remain
on you longer.
So if you're bored, well, it's going to hurt
what you're saying.
So, the principles I think are the same.
This format is extreme. It is more hierarchical.
There's one speaker, and it's less interactive.
It's all true, and that is a difference.
But, if I'm preparing to talk to five people,
and I know I have these three important things
I want to say, all the stuff -- the same stuff
works.
I don't want to make a 50-thing slide deck.
I want to think about what questions am I
going to get asked?
That's actually a question I get a lot about,
What do you do when people interrupt you?
What do you do? Well, you plan for that.
If you know who you're presenting with, you
know your audience, who's likely to ask -- you
know people's hot buttons and you know the
things they most like to go into rat holes
about.
So you plan for that, and you anticipate that.
And you can't control it completely, but if
you're afraid of that thing, then you practice
to prepare for those situations.
Q Okay. My other question is probably on the
other extreme with the -- you probably know
this one's coming up.
It's about the back channels and the presenting
back channels.
Scott Berkun: Yes, the back channel.
Q There's been -- so just to put this in context.
There's the big -- usually at the bigger forums
and there might be some sort of Twitter back
channel going on or other back channels and
sometimes these are presented.
So, what is your take on how a presenter should
deal with this and kind of vibes from the
audience?
Scott Berkun: Okay. So the question is -- for
those of you who don't know -- at some conferences
now, where there's support of Twitter, they
have a screen on -- in some cases behind the
speaker -- that shows the Twitter stream.
So as people in the audience -- it's up there.
You can do whatever you want.
And so, there have been some bad experiences
that speakers have had at some recent conferences.
And I spoke at a conference recently, where
they had this up there.
The short answer is that, you never have anyone's
complete attention anyway.
You never do.
And so, again, if people tune out, they want
to do their laptop.
It's going to happen. It's just natural.
It's got nothing to do entirely with you.
The better you are as a speaker -- the better
you match what you're talking about to what
they're interested in, again, the $500 million
thing -- the more likely it is that you can
keep their attention.
But I know I never have everybody -- Obama
never has everybody -- no one ever has everybody.
The other challenge is, sometimes the way
the room feels is different from how the room
actually is.
That the room can seem cold, but maybe there's
some bad news that was mentioned that morning.
Or maybe -- there could be something else
going on in the environment that has nothing
to do with you.
And you have to have a -- kind of tune that
out.
You're going to do your thing, and you're
listening, but you can't read too much into
how they're responding, unless they're throwing
things at you.
Now, the Twitter thing -- I'm like, "Great.
If you guys are bored with me, and you want
to have a side conversation in the background,
that's fine."
Like, putting it behind me?
You're now putting that in competition with
what I'm trying to do, and that's just unfair.
I mean, it's hard enough to speak.
There's enough stresses and challenges in
speaking at all.
This is adding a degree of difficulty, because
now, I can't even see what it is.
And it allows anyone -- ANYONE -- to participate.
And I'm all for participation, but 'anyone'?
I mean, it's like heckler fodder.
You're giving this environment, where they
have an abstract name, where no one might
even know who they are.
How does that add value?
So the question I ask about any of that stuff
is, What problem are you trying to solve?
If the problem is people are bored, well,
you probably need better speakers or you need
to coach the speakers better, so they're more
attuned to what the audience wants.
Then the need for the back channel is diminished.
Not that it shouldn't exist, but the need
for it goes away.
Yeah. Yep.
Q Quick question.
It almost sounds like we should be making
movies, not presentations.
Do you think that's a better way of thinking
of it?
Of an arc and engaging people's attention
that way?
Scott Berkun: Yes and no.
So I believe that, yes, in that you are thinking
about narrative and story and keeping people
engaged, so absolutely.
But a movie is an artifact. It's a crafted
production.
And I'm a believer that -- I don't think,
most of the time, that's what people want.
They want something that feels natural and
authentic and real, because that actually
keeps your attention better.
If you think that a lot of the stuff that
people are afraid of -- like their personality
or the fact that they have opinions or they're
animated, that those are negatives, that it's
unprofessional to do those things.
And my experience is, it's just the opposite.
So you don't want it to be so polished that
it's its own -- like it's a work of art.
You want it to serve a purpose, and the audience
feels like you're a real person who really
believes what you're saying.
So, I try to find the sweet spot with anything
I use -- I don't want that to overpower -- some
people make beautiful slides.
Like, they're like beautiful.
You know, they spent hours on this.
And it could be overwhelming.
That can draw way more of your attention away
from the message or the points you're trying
to make or the reasons people came.
They probably didn't come to see works of
art on your slides while you're talking about
something else over them.
It's probably not why they're there.
So I do agree on the movie thing from a narrative
and functional perspective, but not in the
sense that you should have these perfectly
constructed, highly produced, theatrical performances
-- no.
I think that betrays what most people want
most of the time.
Q One last question.
The slide that you had up there with the heart
rate and time?
Scott Berkun: Yeah.
Q It also, I think, correlates to another
dimension of attention.
So it's 'attention' and 'time'.
Those are the two things that we're dealing
with.
But we have these artificial constructs.
There's societal constructs of 60 minute presentations
or meetings --
Scott Berkun: Yes.
Q -- and we're always bound by that.
Q Are there ways that you've found to be like,
"Screw that.
I'm going to give my presentation in six minutes?
The meeting is over in 12?"
Scott Berkun: Yeah, no one is ever upset -- ever
-- that you ended early.
Like, never, ever, ever, ever.
Never, ever, ever. Never happens.
There's no recording in the history of the
world the meeting ended early -- except unless
they paid to be there, right?
I saw a lecture by David Mamet, the screenwriter.
And he spoke -- and I paid money to see this.
He spoke for like 35 minutes, and said, "Well,
I don't want to take up more of your time."
[Pshuu!] He's gone.
I was like, "What the fuck?" [laughter]
Like, you know, "I paid money. I want more,
you know?"
But in general, less is better.
Always less is better.
And the best thing to do is what I try to
do here -- maybe it worked, maybe it didn't.
25 minutes is a decent chunk of time.
Give people enough like, Is this guy credible
or not?
Then I open the floor.
If there were no questions, that's a vote
of, "We're done."
If there are questions, that means -- at least
for some people -- there's more they wanted,
let's keep going.
So I'm always like, "I'll keep going as long
as people have questions.
There's no questions, well, I don't want to
bore you anymore.
Let's go."
So standing meetings.
Have you heard of 'standing meetings.'?
Similar principle, right? Yeah.
Q So we have about ten more minutes left.
I wanted to ask a question.
And then, if anybody's on VC and wanted to
ask something, you can jump in right after
Scott's finished with the answer on this.
Scott Berkun: Okay.
Q So the name of the book is "Confessions
of a Public Speaker," which sort of 'confessions'
has like a bit of a negative connotation.
Like, they're revealing something bad.
And I think when you were researching the
book you had solicited examples of when the
presentation had gone horribly wrong.
Is there some example or anecdote that stood
out in your mind from that research?
Scott Berkun: Yeah, so there's a chapter in
the book.
There's two chapters in the book that are
related to that.
One chapter in the book is called, "What to
do when things go wrong."
And it's an index of all the things people
are usually afraid of, and they've all happened
to me.
And how to prevent them from happening.
And what to do if it happens anyway.
So it's like this 'countermove' thing in the
book for the stuff people are usually worried
about.
Although, these things don't tend to happen
that often.
And the last chapter in the book, I went around
to all the other people who I know are sort
of like me -- who are authors or famous people
-- who end up, as a by-product, doing a lot
of speaking.
They're not actors or, you know, motivational
speakers or anything.
And I took all their best stories.
So one of my favorites is Dan Roam.
You guys know who Dan Roam is?
Back of the Napkin.
He wrote this book called "Back of the Napkin."
And he has a story in there about speaking
in Russia years ago.
And midway through his presentation, a bunch
of -- the equivalent of a SWAT team -- the
Moscow like, SWAT team comes barging in, and
with AK-47s and the whole deal and go to the
four corners of the room.
They identify the person they're looking for,
they grab him, and then, they leave.
[laughter] Like, how do you follow that?
Like, do you try to explain?
Or do you just pretend it didn't happen?
So that's one of my favorite stories.
Like, that's like, you know, all the things
you worry about, like that's something to
worry about.
Like a terrorist group coming in and invading
your thing.
Once AK-47s enter the situation, it's a whole
another game, I think.
Q Was there anybody on VC?
I don't even know if anybody's there.
Okay. Well, let's give Scott a round of applause.
Thanks for coming.
Scott Berkun: Thanks guys.
>> [Clapping]